so if you're john davis or if you're
anyone else who's challenging me
you have a 1 in 50 chance of being the
next opponent
oh playing emmy triple nine
good luck okay so there is request
i still have to play a tumbleweed okay
i'll play
this is casual so at least with casual i
should really make a rule with with
rated challenges i won't mess around
but with casual challenges tumbleweed
variation let's go
hi eric i recently bought your course on
the london
opening and i've been working through
the tactics love your style that's nice
to hear
made that course a couple years ago now
but yeah it's the type of thing that
shouldn't go too
outdated okay so this is my first ever
tumbleweed
not quite like the london
um but this is the point where okay i'll
start playing serious chess
um i mean this is of course a threat
maybe i can just take
i'll just take and then d4 preventing
bishop
c5 preparing the service please consider
putting this whole stream on y
team fun times
i'll consider it yeah it's been a lot of
eventful moments of stream
i feel like there are a lot of questions
maybe i didn't quite address earlier
um i think someone was asking about book
you scroll down here
there's something book related
i'm gonna keep queens on the board i had
the the chance for queenie one or queen
e2
[Music]
but i'm having a feeling that
king is is less safe than my king
it's on the open file i have initiative
i really want to play this move
there's a really cool idea here i think
i'm going to play it
yeah this is a really cool move
the whole point is i'm i'm breaking the
pin so the bishop will no longer be
pinned
even after pawn takes and i sack the
knight i have bishop g5
with a counter it's like a pin skewer
and if queen takes i have a very simple
move rook e3
and then there's a double threat of
bishop f5 or bishop b5 winning the queen
but also just bishop takes b bishop
takes e7
um whoa whoa it's john
john appreciates this move because yeah
now i have a very pleasant choice
of of how to win the queen thanks sean
for the ten thousand knight of three
bits
actually i'll play bishop b5
because it's not sacking the bishop
immediately and when i take back i'll
pin the f pawn
and yeah this is wow this is completely
winning
it's before move 20. yeah let's just
sack
sacking almost everything uh there's
this move
queen g7 i was gone did the king get to
e4
gone dude oh no it got to f2
i played king f2 on move three in this
game
okay let's just keep checking the king
until
until it's mate but where's the mate
between c7
oh no my bishop
and then check and then this is meat
okay that was a fun game it was like a
tumbleweed miniature
so black's king was a real tumbleweed it
was like tumbling all over the board
that's a weird game i think black
like black played probably what you
should do except
this is probably the the critical move
i assume this is a refutation too of the
tumbleweed
oh leachate even knows the name of this
i thought this was just like a troll
opening
i guess lee chass is still aware of
troll openings
does it call this sabon cloud oh it does
wow
nicholas is so knowledgeable
so this this is just much worse than the
bond clap because the pawn's already
here and black has
this move i was gonna play probably g3
and then king g2
and i think the point is like you you
just give away all your kingside pawns
so you have all these open files to work
with or at least half open files
and you get more development minus
minus four for black
okay maybe that's youtube worthy
my first ever tumbleweed variation
and maybe my last ever i don't know if i
want to repeat this opening
and don't mess with the tumbleweed oh
john is already picturing the thumbnail
oh with like a tumbleweed right on the
board
what does a tumbleweed even look like
you see them in cartoons but they're
oh they're real things right
i don't think i've ever seen a
tumbleweed in real life
okay i just googled tumbleweed this was
one of the first
one of the first video oh it's a
tumbleweed wow so it's like a
it's a dead plant it's just blown in the
wind
wow
they grope flowers nestled between
thorny leaves
okay inside each flower a fruit
with a single seed develops this fruit
is
different than something delicious like
cherries lucky for the cherry tree
a bird will carry the fruit away in its
belly and
disperse its seeds come fall the plant
dries out and dies
sad the seeds are still in there
oh that's how they pollinate the dead
tumbleweed from its roots
see where it was attached it looks kind
of like bones
a special layer of cells at the base of
the plant makes this
clean break possible then the skeleton
is off
shaking loose thousands of seeds as it
goes
it turns out some living things spread
their seeds better
when they're dead wow that's so
[Music]
that's so resourceful
so i don't know how that relates to king
f2
premium content excellent tumble weed
analysis
so i guess i i guess the goal of this
opening is just to die
but then to spread the seeds because the
king is
the king can run around i don't know
yeah the king is better when it's dead
yeah
okay so many metaphors to life